csgo is in its off season and thus
things have been pretty slow but over
the weekend we were given a morsel of
content in the form of the 2022 hltv
Awards and with some of the greatest
across CS history and attendance we got
a pretty amazing show there were a ton
of fun and inspiring Awards simple broke
yet another record and N A guess what
they went home with a big fat goosehead
which is not surprising but
I mean come on they did US dirty
let's talk about it
[Music]
okay so before we get into the show
itself I feel that hltv needs a bit of
an explanation itself for those that are
new to CS in fact I'm sure there's a ton
of Cs go diehards who don't exactly know
who they are or what exactly it is they
do one standing for Half-Life hltv
started as a website that held 1.6 demo
files and IP addresses for pro matches
eventually it grew into a news forum for
all things Counter-Strike including
analytics news coverage a podcast and
much much more however it was their
inclusion of in-depth CS go analytics
and their now Infamous rating system
that really changed the game for them to
this day they're used as a resource for
the most important CS go statistics now
while all that was going on they also
launched a list back in 2010 it was
meant to highlight the best players of
the year and since then there has been
an annual iteration of the hltv top 20.
but since the end of the 2022 season
marked the 10th anniversary for the list
hltv decided to do something special
with coveted restrictions lifted h TV
pulled all the stops with a live full
audience award show where they invited
pros from the last 10 years of Cs to
celebrate the game and receive Awards in
a ton of different categories so who
were the big Winners well to start off
since this was the first big in-person
show they had to retroactively give
players like Get Right the massive
[__] awards that they've won over the
years once that was squared away the
full show started so let me rapid fire
some of these Awards kicking things off
was the best five of the Year Awards
which was selected by a panel of 31
judges mostly made up of Cs GoPros the
idea was the panel would vote on and
award the best player in a specific role
on a standard CS go team to then create
a super team and the winners were Nico
for opener axile for closer Perfecto for
anchor simple for Opera and Kerrigan for
igl oh and I guess blade for coach of
the year which which would technically
make it the best six of the year
why didn't they just do that anyway
those were CS Go's best five of the year
and with it included some speeches we
got Perfecto shouting out his parents
does first often say it's thank you for
my family who support me every day of my
career it's my mom and my father who
know all maps now you know all position
and Exile getting surprisingly
sentimental and remember when you are
resting someone working and becoming
better
I want to wish you
I want to wish everyone to be proud of
yourself in your life and make your
dreams come true thank you
now as I said this was voted on by a
panel of Judges which I actually think
was pretty Democratic so yes zaiwu
didn't make Opera of the year but if you
have a problem take it up with the 17
Pros who decided that now moving on to
the awards without a panel things got a
bit spicier and well Up For Debate
starting off with the most controversial
snacks presenting the highlight of the
year which was awarded to monacy for his
1v4 clutch against mibr there's a little
double and might as well have been a
triple dead bonuses in a lot of trouble
he no scopes one of them he keeps going
10 seconds he fakes the ball spins
around takes down Woody and now he said
the hunt running up close and personal
oh what a flick it doesn't have the time
yes he doesn't have to move so much now
there is a Molotov on Turtle he's gonna
throw it it's not deep enough money she
still could have the shot oh and there
it is one of the best clutches we've
seen in a long long time now I do get
why this is special monessey is a
literal teenager and dropping a play
like this in your debut is beyond
incredible but as people have pointed
out online it was against mibr no
offense to them they're a good team in
their own right but
they're not phase in comparison robs's
Ace clutch against G2 was in a match
point situation which forced overtime
and led to phase eventually winning it
was a clutch in the original sense of
the word hell if we're talking about
plays with real impact what about twists
back to back Silo plays to win cologne I
know it wasn't technically a clutch but
come on it was probably Na's only way of
winning a [__] award and we lost it
so I can understand why people would be
a bit jilted actually while we're on the
topic twist didn't even crack the top 10
this year he was 11th and the closest we
got was que serado at nine which further
proves my hypothesis that Brazil is the
best country in na now you might be
saying Devin you love Brazil and yes of
course I do but I'm also Canadian and
therefore legally required to go to bat
for twists whenever necessary
that and I work with Dimitri imagine
hearing him complain all day anyway the
rest of the awards weren't as
controversial modesty was also given
Rookie of the Year for obvious reasons
nigma and FaZe won teams of the year and
Anna was awarded woman player of the
year but those final two awards were
actually important for a few reasons for
starters it's nice to finally see some
mainstream recognition of women CS go I
even saw some debate online if other
women were snubbed of awards which is
honestly fantastic over the last year
we've seen games like valorent make a
ton of progress in the name of
representation but recently CS go has
been lagging behind quite severely I
know it's not much but an award is a
step in the right direction amount of
struggles and tears and Prejudice we had
to overcome
is you know
it's a lot
but we never give up because we have a
bigger goal to achieve and I really hope
that one day we will see mixed teams
where girls and boys are playing
together and we will do everything in
our power to make this day closer
after all of those lovely Awards we
finally got to the moment everyone was
waiting for hltv's Player of the Year as
I mentioned the top 20 list is what
kicked everything off for hltv way back
when and leading up to the show this
year they were slowly drip feeding their
list leaving only three to be announced
in person these were the results in
third place was Shiro zaiwu was named
runner-up and in first place hltv's
player of the year was awarded to
it was simple it was obviously simple it
goes too simple
[Applause]
[Music]
as a result of this win simple became
the first player in history to win the
award three times with Caldera zaibu and
get right all tied with two it was yet
another record-breaking moment for the
goat in a year filled with plenty of
other accolades but when in front of the
mic simple explained that this year had
been far from perfect I never understand
people who had like depression or they
had some sadness and 300 days ago I
actually felt this I actually felt that
I lost myself I actually wanted to
become better in 2022 and I wanted my
team to become better but the war
happened and it was very tough for me
and finally understand what means to be
in some depressed situation
so it's pretty tough but it feels like
excuse right I mean I feel like
I feel everything else is excuses you
know we can all of you and
me especially we can we can be much much
uh Stronger inside you all in all I
think the award show was a success at
least from a viewer's standpoint I'm not
the biggest award show guy out there but
it's nice to have something to celebrate
CS at the end of the year hopefully hltv
continues to expand on this format and
it becomes something that we actually
look forward to every year with that
being said what did you think did you
love it did you hate it did you even
watch it do you think anyone got snubbed
and most importantly who is your
favorite player of the year
let us know in the comments please and
as always I'll see you in the next one
whoever's recording this
the intro will be at the end
whoever's editing this thank you
oh hello Andrew
um
all right everything looks good